ich vor da für alle Lebensmittel
produzierenden Betriebe dass wir den
gleichen Preis bekommen der vorgesehen
ist wie für die Industrie denn es kann
nicht sein dass eine absolute
Wettbewerbsverzerrung stattfinden darf
in diesem Bereich das bedeutet ganz klar
dass das dass die Industrie beurteilt
wird gegenüber dem kleinen Handwerk wie
es bisher vorgesehen ist sind KMU das
heißt kleine und mittelständige
Unternehmen genau so eingestuft wie
privathaushaltet das funktioniert leider
für uns nicht wir sind sowohl
energieintensiv als auch
personalintensiv und Herr Harbig sie
müssen einfach handeln wir brauchen
jetzt Unterstützung damit wir weiterhin
nächstes Jahr backen können damit wir
regional gesunde Lebensmittel herstellen
können und damit einfach die
Arbeitsplätze viele viele Arbeitsplätze
in Deutschland erhalten bleiben
viele Dienstleister oder Firmen
Industriebetriebe die erhöhen ja einfach
die Preise und geben das dann an ihre
Handelspartner weiter und sagen dann es
tut uns leid der Gaspreis ist so sehr
gestiegen das können sie beim Brötchen
ja würde ich sagen nicht machen die
gestiegenen Preise einfach weitergeben
oder nee das funktioniert nicht mehr
weil es einfach ein riesen Kosten
Tsunami ist weil natürlich die
Lieferanten alle schon die Preise erhöht
haben dadurch dass es Corona gab das
Lieferketten unterbrochen wurden ist es
sowieso schon massiv in die Höhe
gegangen dann durch den Krieg sind die
vor allem Mehl extrem teuer geworden
also das heißt unsere Rohstoffe die
haben sich teilweise mehr als verdoppelt
massiv ist da sind alle Rohstoffe aber
massiv zu nennen ist dabei Butter gerade
und vor allem Mehl und wenn jetzt diese
Energiekosten auf uns zukommen und man
muss sagen 15 Prozent so ist geschätzt
von den backenden Betrieben sind schon
betroffen die nächsten 50 Prozent werden
im Dezember bzw Januar betroffen sein
und die anderen dann Mitte nächsten
Jahres diese massiv gestiegenen Kosten
das kann man nicht mehr an den Kunden
weitergeben weil keiner ist bereit von
Brot 1,5 oder für ein Brötchen 1,50 € zu
zahlen und wenn sie es wäre 1,50 € pro
Brötchen wenn man die Kosten alle
weitergeben würde also ich kann es nicht
genau sagen also das ist immer ganz
schwierig kalkulieren also wenn wir
diesen diesen Deckel der jetzt für uns
vorgesehen ist wie wir es gelegen sind
haben von der erstmal schon von der
gaspreiskommission und jetzt steht ja
auch für Strom eigentlich fest das ist
für uns auch 40 Cent sein sollen wo wir
doch von 15 kommen ich betone das immer
wieder weil es eben einige Politiker
leider nicht wissen
dann weiß ich nicht das ist das ist so
ein Kosten Tsunami nein ich glaube nicht
dass das wir Grundversorger bleiben
können und wir sind ein Grundversorger
man darf nicht vergessen dass wir
wirklich ein Grundnahrungsmittel
herstellen und wir sind systemrelevant
und ich sage es ganz klar es sind die
Fleischer es sind die Molkereien es sind
die Müller die Müller sagen jetzt ganz
klar zu uns ja Mehl nächstes Jahr
einerseits diese horrenden Preise für
Weizen aber natürlich auch die massiv
begebenen Energiekosten also die haben
meistens Strom und dann sind wir einfach
wir kommen bei mailpreis von keine
Ahnung 35 Euro und sollen dann jetzt an
die 70 Euro zahlen schaffen sie noch die
Ladenzeiten einzuhalten also ich habe
hier ein Lieblingsbäcker um die Ecke
beim Axel-Springer-Verlag und der hat
jetzt letztendlich um 16 Uhr zugemacht
obwohl seine Zeit eigentlich bis 19 Uhr
offen ist weil er war einfach die
Mitarbeiter gefehlt haben kennen Sie das
Problem auch oder ja
nein das ist absolut so also Mitarbeiter
ist ein riesen Riesenproblem wir kämpfen
seit Jahren dass eben das Handwerk
wieder eine Revolution erlebt und das
ganz viele Menschen den handwerklichen
Beruf erlernen weil er einfach auch so
sinnvoll ist also ich selbst bin
Lehrerin Akademiker und bin absolut
Handwerks verliebt und nicht nur in
meinen Mann sondern tatsächlich auch
wirklich in den Beruf weil ich einfach
weiß wie soll es funktionieren woher
sollen gesunde Lebensmittel kommen wenn
wir sie nicht mehr produzieren und das
sind ja nicht nur Lebensmittel sind die
Tischler wir uns fehlen so viele
Fachkräfte ja warum fehlen die warum ist
es so weil es einfach ja die letzten
Jahre medial auch glaube ich teilweise
unterstützt ich weiß es nicht genau ob
es nur daran liegt aber es ist schon der
Tenor du musst studieren sonst bist du
nichts wert und sonst kannst du auch
kein Geld verdienen und das stimmt
einfach nicht das kann man gut wenn man
fleißig ist dann funktioniert das im
Handwerk genauso aber so schwierig wie
es uns jetzt gemacht wird und dass wir
völlig vergessen werden wenn man hört
seit Wochen reden die Politiker ob es
Herr Scholz ist Herr Habeck Herr Lindner
alle sagen die Bäcker die Bäcker wir
stehen ja praktisch für den Mittelstand
sind wir das Gesicht und wie würden wir
bedacht gar nicht das funktioniert nicht